this video was made possible by
curiosity stream watch an exclusive
companion video to this by signing up
for the nebula bundle deal at
curiositystream.com
wendover
on august 15th 2021 taliban fighters
encircled kabul over the hours days and
weeks prior they had swept across the
nation toppling provincial capital after
provincial capital
now their grand prize their return to
rule after 20 years of war with the west
was within sight
as police put on street clothes
retailers raised the price of burqas and
workers painted over pictures of women
hamid karzai international airport
maintained an eerie impression of
normalcy it was certainly busy with
civilians fleeing on commercial flights
governments evacuating their diplomatic
staff and airlines relocating their
aircraft to more stable nations but the
way cabell's airport operated that
morning was broadly the way it operated
any morning
at 10 42 am a pakistan international
airlines triple 7200 landed from
islamabad at 11 26 a qatar airways
triple 7 300 er touched down on a
charter flight from doha shortly after
at 11 49 a cam air a340 left on its
daily run to delhi in spite of the
foreboding feeling in the air the
airport fulfilled its regular role for
the bustling middle eastern metropolis
but then came the news
shortly after noon the taliban spoke
person zabahula mujahid issued a
statement their forces had encircled
kabul and they intended to enter still
the planes kept coming having allocated
each one of their seats to those lucky
enough to find an available ticket as an
air india a320 approached however atc
stopped responding with panic setting in
on the ground controllers had abandoned
their posts so in the air the a320
entered a holding pattern until its
pilots determined a course of action
twelve thousand feet above an emirates
triple seven did the same until it
diverted back to dubai but one hour
later finally the air india aircraft
successfully landed in the hours that
followed without any atc clearance the
pakistan international airlines triple 7
qatar airways triple 7 air india a320
and a pakistan international airlines
a320 each departed for their
destinations but the most significant
departure was not one of the afternoon's
planes but a passenger aboard it
at 4 56 pm tolo news one of
afghanistan's largest broadcasters
reported that president ashraf ghani had
fled the country
the islamic republic of afghanistan was
no longer
the taliban
were in control
soon after its forces entered kabul at 7
38 pm a km air 737 left on the afghan
airlines regular evening run to
islamabad representing kabul's last
regularly scheduled commercial flight
for days weeks or maybe more
meanwhile the taliban took control of
the ark afghanistan's presidential
palace and the first photos emerged
displaying the finality of the situation
reactions around kabul were mixed
some celebrated the jihadist group does
have some public support so kabul
streets were roamed by men enjoying what
was in their minds a victorious night
others including nearly all women hidden
their homes worried for potential
violence and for the future of their
country
then there were those who feared for
their lives journalists activists former
government officials along with
interpreters security guards and others
who had worked with american nato and
nato allied forces the desperation was
undoubtedly profound because as soon as
kabul's fall was no longer in question
scores of people worked their way
through the streets towards the same
destination
kabul airport the taliban already
controlled every one of afghanistan's
land border crossings so the airport was
truly the singular way out for those who
needed to leave
surrounded by dense urban sprawl and
located mere miles from the city center
hamid karzai international airport is a
nightmare from a perimeter security
perspective it was hardly difficult for
those who flock there to scale its walls
and across the evening of august 15th
thousands made it onto the airfield
desperate to find any flight with any
seat going anywhere but afghanistan in
the days leading up to the fall of kabul
the us had ramped up its evacuation
efforts largely in the mission of
evacuating its diplomatic staff before
the situation deteriorated further
therefore it had already deployed
thousands of troops and effectively
relocated its embassy and the key staff
that ran it to the airport amidst the
chaos a single c7 team was scheduled to
depart filled with hundreds of
individuals adorned with a wristband
indicating that they had been authorized
to travel on an american evacuation
flight due to their status as an
individual believed to be in acute
danger under taliban rule the manifest
for this flight reach 871 soon became
moot as hundreds who were not assigned
to the particular flight but were
cleared to fly rushed the cargo bay the
aircraft became packed far beyond its
operating limit but faced with the
alternative of spending hours reloading
the aircraft properly as the airfield's
condition decayed further reach 871's
commander chose to break protocol and
take off at 1 27 am on august 16th
823 passengers were packed onto the
aircraft's floor easily breaking the
record for the most people carried by a
c-17
as the sun rose on the first day of the
second era of taliban rule in
afghanistan a brief lull from chaos
along with the official announcement
that the u.s military had taken over air
traffic control at the airport allowed a
turkish airlines triple 7 a civilian
aircraft that just the day prior had
flown a regular flight from san
francisco to istanbul to land in order
to pick up turkish citizens still left
in the country it parked on the military
side of the airport north of the runway
around which military forces had
established a security perimeter over
the following hours as the aircraft
loaded the situation deteriorated once
again
satellite imagery taken at 10 36 a.m
displays the state of chaos
the airport's southern gate was
thoroughly breached with individuals
flowing freely through
four military vehicles appeared to be
working to contain crowds of people to
the civilian aircraft apron others had
already made it further and were strewn
across the runway a line of u.s military
vehicles denoted their security
perimeter preventing anyone from
advancing further north into the
military area of the airport from where
evacuation flights were leaving two
other vehicles flanked the crowd on each
side to prevent the runway incursion
from widening meanwhile to the east the
turkish airlines triple 7 sat idle
filled with its evacuees just waiting
for a clear runway in order to take off
without much progress it later taxied
back to the apron as the military worked
to clear the runway they were successful
enough that a u.s air force c-17 was
able to land at 12 30 pm but the
aircraft was quickly swarmed by these
same crowds
as apache helicopters flew low across
the runway in an attempt to clear people
away the c-17s pilots decided to depart
immediately without dropping off their
cargo or loading evacuees inexplicably
dozens of individuals clung to the
aircraft as it taxied and some perhaps
unaware of the aircraft's intention to
take off did not let go
gruesome video soon emerged depicting
two individuals falling hundreds of feet
to their death after takeoff and human
remains were later found in the
aircraft's wheel well upon its return to
qatar
this included fada mohammed a young
dentist from the outskirts of kabul and
zaki anwari a teenage soccer star who
played centre-back on the country's
youth national team
perhaps the crowns were rattled by their
deaths perhaps the military took them as
a sign to intensify their efforts or
perhaps something entirely different
occurred but one way or another the
runway was cleared and two u.s air force
c-130 hercules aircraft were able to
depart around 12 50 pm the turkish
airlines triple 7 left 25 minutes after
that the rest of the afternoon of august
16th was more of the same planes would
land and take off for a period the
situation would intensify flights would
halt and then start again once the chaos
settled down
white house evacuation numbers suggest
that the record-breaking early morning
c-17 flight was likely the only
departure to include civilian evacuees
on august 16th as little success was had
in the afternoon with the airfield in
such a state of anarchy meanwhile seven
thousand miles or eleven thousand
kilometers away joe biden was on board
marine one making the brief 40 minute
flight from camp david the presidential
country retreat to the white house
the fact that the president was on
vacation was indicative of the situation
his administration never expected the
taliban to conquer kabul so quickly the
criticism for the bungling of the
withdrawal was resounding just 26 of
americans surveyed supported the
president's handling of the situation
and his overall approval rating took a
nosedive by the evening of august 16th
kabul had fallen the airport was in a
state of chaos and there was little the
biden administration could do to remedy
the situation upon landing at the white
house the president walked into the east
room and as dozens of cameras stared him
down he made his first public statement
since the fall of cabell after a defiant
rebuttal of criticism over the
withdrawal decision and sober
condolences to those affected by the
situation the topic shifted towards the
ongoing evacuation effort with biden
saying quote our current military
mission will be short in time limited in
scope and focused in its objectives get
our people and our allies to safety as
quickly as possible
the evacuation was all that was left of
the 20-year war in afghanistan so it was
the last mission that could sway public
opinion of the white house's handling of
the situation
therefore the combined efforts of dozens
of government agencies were all
concentrated on getting as many
endangered people as possible out of
afghanistan as soon as possible
by the end of the week of august 15th
after days of steady but slower progress
the pieces had been put in place to
initiate a dramatic ramp up in
evacuations for any individual eligible
to take an american flight typically
through status as an american citizen
resident or special immigrant visa
holder or applicant the first step was
to actually get to the airport
this was no small feat the taliban had
set up two checkpoints on airport road
the main route to the airport
purportedly to control the flow of
people and prevent further chaos
while official taliban policy was to
allow anyone authorized for evacuation
by the us or other nations through there
is often disconnect between policy and
practice with the group so whether
someone safely and successfully made it
to the airport was largely up to the
discretion of the individual taliban
fighters operating such checkpoints the
main civilian entrance to the airport
was under taliban control so evacuees
were typically instructed to make their
way to the abbey east or north gates
from there if they could work their way
through the crowds and chaos their
eligibility for evacuation would be
checked and a member of the military
would pat them down to check for weapons
before letting them through
evacuees would then make their way to
the apron on the military side of the
airport where they'd load onto typically
a c-17 or c-130 to maximize capacity
floor loading procedures were used where
cargo straps were laid across the floor
for passengers to hold onto during
takeoff landing and turbulence
this way the passenger density was far
higher than if using seats as the cargo
bay doors closed on each flight hundreds
of evacuees glimpsed out at what would
almost certainly be their final view of
the country they called home
from there american evacuation flights
typically flew southwest for three hours
landing at alude air base in qatar this
is the largest u.s military installation
in the middle east and in many ways acts
as its headquarters of operations in the
region for this mission the base served
as an interim stopover point as the
evacuees awaited an initial round of
security screening before onward travel
conditions were undoubtedly rough
the military used cavernous aircraft
hangars and temporary cots to house the
evacuees but with limited climate
control engineers struggled to find
solutions to keep the space cool in the
intense heat of the qatari desert aoud
air base quickly became a bottleneck and
on august 20th flights out of kabul were
halted for a few hours as the facility
reached capacity the global us military
logistics system kicked into gear though
as portable air-conditioned tents and
toilets were flown in to increase
capacity and improve conditions the main
focus however was to get evacuees out of
guitar as fast as possible move them
towards their destination
and make room for more to enable this
the president activated the rarely used
civil reserve air fleet essentially in
order to compete for regular peacetime
contracts to transport u.s military
members and supplies around the world
airlines in the u.s sign up as part of
this reserve air fleet which can be
activated when an emergency dictates
that a need for aircraft capacity
exceeds the practical capacity of u.s
military aircraft
this was such an instance
therefore 18 aircraft from american
airlines atlas air united airlines delta
airlines omni air international hawaiian
airlines and united airlines were called
into service to assist with evacuations
for example this united airlines triple
seven three hundred tail number
n2352u landed at al ud at 10 19 pm on
august 22nd
it spent four hours on the ground then
ferried a full load of evacuees six
hours west to ramstein air base in
germany
ramstein similar to alude is the largest
american base in europe and effectively
operates at the scale of a small city
with up to 50 000 americans living in
and around the base one of its major
roles is to provide logistics
capabilities meaning it quite often
serves as a stopping point for military
aircraft traveling between the us and
the middle east
therefore it had the perfect position
and scale to relieve stress from al-udid
in the more hospitable german climate
there was no longer the issue of
inhumane heat so the military set up a
sprawling complex of tents and cots
evacuated kids were even able to set up
a daily soccer match on a patch of grass
civilian volunteers helped distribute
mountains of donated clothes sanitary
products toys and more to the evacuees
who had to leave almost all their
possessions behind only permitted to
take a single back after further
security screening and immigration
processing evacuees were ready to
finally head to the united states the
same aforementioned united airlines
triple seven loaded up to fly this leg
for the first time on august 23rd and
then made the seven and a half hour
flight west to dulles airport just
outside washington dc upon landing
evacuees were tested for kovid processed
through immigration and finally took
their first steps into the united states
from there though it was more of the
same they were bused to the nearby
dulles expo center which acted as
temporary housing as they awaited
further travel in the hours or days
waiting there each evacuee was offered a
coveted vaccine and additional donated
items some were bussed to nearby maguire
air force base fort lee marine corps
base quantico or fort pickett while
others boarded further flights to fort
mccoy in wisconsin fort bliss in texas
or holloman air force base in new mexico
these bases served as slightly
longer-term housing for the evacuees as
they awaited a final round of
immigration processing before being
connected with a refugee resettlement
organization to assist them in setting
up their new lives somewhere in the
united states
this entire evacuation process happened
at a breakneck pace kabul to
alodi to ramstein and ramstein to dulles
likely became the busiest three
international flight routes in the world
for a few days even as other bases in
kuwait italy spain and elsewhere were
brought online as interim stopping
points to relieve pressure on this main
evacuation route as well the system was
able to ramp up to a peak of 13 000
evacuations a day on u.s military
aircraft as well as an additional 9 000
on civilian and allied military aircraft
on august 24th
the system was also however
imperfect
one crucial weakness was that the u.s
military's role in administering kabul
airport required at least some direct
interface between service members and
the general public
specifically that occurred here at abby
gates where troops checked individuals
eligibility to enter and search them for
weapons
this was necessary to ensure the safety
of the flights
in theory most people at this location
would have already passed through
taliban security checkpoints but these
were irregular and imperfect
consequently taking advantage of the
densely packed chaos on august 26 at 5
50 p.m a suicide bomber from isis k
detonated their explosive vest and a
gunman from the terrorist group then
fired into the crowd
169 civilians and 13 american service
members were killed
by the 26th the bulk of the evacuation
was already completed and so the suicide
bombing had little effect on the success
of the mission one by one over the
coming days american allied nations
announced the last of their evacuation
flights and the end of their presence in
afghanistan australia france new zealand
italy and more finished on the 27th the
uk the second most involved nation in
the evacuations finished its effort on
the 28th with all of its troops out of
the country by the following day
then on august 30th a few minutes before
midnight ross wilson acting u.s
ambassador to afghanistan boarded a c-17
followed by chris donahue commanding
general of the 82nd airborne division
behind him the cargo bay door closed the
aircraft taxied
rolled down the runway
took off
and banked towards the south
with that moment for the first time in
19 years
10 months three weeks and two days the
us military had no presence in
afghanistan and the war was
finally and officially
over
even once each of these tens of
thousands of evacuees are safely in the
u.s the process is far from over
right now one of the largest and fastest
resettlement efforts in history is
kicking into gear and the logistics of
helping such a massive people set up new
lies in such a short amount of time are
also fascinating as this video was
already getting far too long i made
another video on that topic and put it
exclusively on nebula i'm able to do
that because nebula was built by
creators including myself from the
ground up to be able to enable us to
make even better and more unique content
that's why i've been able to make
multiple big budget nebula originals
release my regular videos there early
and ad-free and do these exclusive
companion videos we also want new
viewers to be able to watch our stuff on
there so we've partnered with
curiositystream to make it super easy to
get access
any curiosity stream subscription signed
up for at curiositystream.comwendover
includes access to nebula so that means
you get two streaming sites for the
price of one of course on curiosity
stream you could watch anything from
their enormous catalog of non-fiction
shows and documentaries including
afghanistan 1979 a fantastic documentary
about the soviet afghan war that was the
major contributing factor to the
establishment of the taliban all of this
curiosity stream and nebula together
comes at a truly fantastic price with a
bundle deal just
14.79 a year with the current sale which
is just one dollar and 23 cents a month
signing up helps provide steady
predictable income to loads of
independent creators large and small
that you probably already watch and is
genuinely a great deal so click this
button or head to curiositystream.com
wendover